hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear and it's another installment of
jell-o july i'm having actually a really
good time doing these and i hope you
guys are too i have gotten a lot of good
feedback about this so apparently
there's a lot of other jello junkies out
there that are very very happy that i
decided to devote a whole month to the
sub genre so if you like it leave me a
comment down below and maybe i'll do
another giallo themed month uh sometime
in the future so let's talk about
lucio folgi
now
nobody would ever
i guess accuse him
uh you know he's he's made like lots of
different types of movies not just
splatter ones but he's probably at least
in the united states he's most famous
for his splatter films like zombie and
uh the beyond and stuff like that
so nobody would ever really accuse him
of being particularly subtle as a
filmmaker
but i have to say even in his sort of
you know the wide span of his work which
includes you know very famously splinter
eye gougings uh somebody coughing up
their intestines a little girl with
braids getting her head half blown off
by a shotgun uh you know spider attacks
things of that nature even in light of
all that uh his 1982
giallo thriller the new york ripper
some of his fans even the most ardent
ones are just kind of like hey i think
you went a little bit too far with that
one i don't think it's so much in terms
of gore but just in the sense of how
sleazy and kind of misanthropic and
nasty and like unpleasant to watch it is
because it's not like some of his other
stuff like house by the cemetery and the
beyond and stuff like that which had
kind of a more surrealist nightmarish
kind of thing so the gore was kind of
like taken a little bit out of a
realistic context this one is very much
you know it's a giallo it's a murder
mystery so it's set very much in
realistic in a realistic kind of
framework and
i think that's something that kind of
makes people like
i don't know like i know i've seen a lot
of like reviews of of you know people
that like lucio folgi's kind of more
fantastical stuff and they're like this
one and they don't really care for it
all that much just because it's so nasty
i kind of feel like this one is probably
it's essentially like a more extreme and
very very italian take on william
lustig's maniac it has like very very
overtly sexual kills there's a lot of
smut in it and i kind of love it or hate
it murderer like with a very peculiar
quirk which we'll get into it a little
bit which is uh which is kind of like
creepy or funny like or both like
depending on how you want to look at it
so i will say just right from the jump
this movie is absolutely not for
everyone although i will defend it in
the sense that i do think it has
some kind of this just squalid kind of
power you know what i mean and i have to
say that
having
watched this movie first
i can't even remember the first time i
saw this it was probably back in the 90s
or the early 2000s at some point
and i think the only stuff that was
available then i think it was available
on dvd but that might have been just
like the vhs transfer so it was like
very shitty looking it's kind of pan and
scan
and it looked like crap which in a way
kind of like suits the subject matter
but uh as with a lot of movies that came
out in this era that i've been noticing
when they're actually like restored and
put out on blu-ray or you know hd or
whatever um the way that they were
initially intended to be seen like in
the theater they actually look amazing
they actually look fantastic and so a
lot of these filmmakers i think that
like back in the 70s or whatever that
were known for being these kind of like
schlock masters because people only saw
their [ __ ] like on vhs or whatever like
now they're kind of seeing it and going
oh they actually were like a
professional filmmaker who knew how to
set up a beautiful shot and stuff like
that and i think that that's this is
definitely a prime example of that blue
underground i believe released um
uh a restored version i believe it's
ultra uh 4k uh in 2020 and it actually
looks
gorgeous i mean the the
just the shots are just beautifully
framed uh the colors look gorgeous and
vibrant and it's just it looks fantastic
like compared to the crappy old vhs
releases that everybody was probably
used to from this movie i mean i feel
like if you're gonna watch trash anyway
uh at least watch it the way it was
intended you know what i mean as
grotesque as it is but this was this is
actually like a quite a beautiful
looking movie uh so it's nice to see it
the way it was originally supposed to be
seen now like many of fulchi's films
during this same time period that he
made around this era
the exteriors of this were actually
filmed in the united states obviously in
new york city in this case but the
interiors were all shot in rome uh the
discrepancy at least to me isn't all
that noticeable and i will say that one
of the best things about this movie is
that it does have this sort of like
grimy
ominous vibe of new york city like in
the late 70s early 80s where you know it
was very dangerous you know kind of life
was cheap every encounter with a
stranger was like fraught with peril
like everyone was out to get you so it
does kind of like convey that very very
well like in its shots of the streets
and whatnot now curiously here's was
something that i didn't know like the
first time that i saw this movie uh that
i just found out when i was doing
research for this video the new york
ripper was initially meant to be
directed by reguero diadato
and it was supposed to center around a
serial killer who suffered from progeria
which is you know a real disease they
mentioned it in one of my favorite
vampire films the hunger from 1983. uh
this is a disease which causes rapid
aging
now
in this original iteration of the
screenplay the cops trying to solve the
case would thus have a difficult time
trying to catch the perp because his
appearance would constantly be changing
you know what i mean it's like you see a
30 year old and now suddenly looks like
a six-year-old you know what i mean uh
so this actually sounds like a pretty
fascinating idea and uh rigero dia datto
would actually utilize it later on in
his 1988 film phantom of death which i
actually haven't seen
but when lucio fulchi got hold of the
concept him and his frequent co-writer
dardano saschatti who i've brought up
before in this very series um they opted
instead to make their version of the new
york ripper
quack like a duck
and no i didn't just make that up he
actually does quack like a duck and kind
of like talk in a duck voice
whether or not they made the right call
uh in this case is entirely up to you
like i said it's i kind of feel like
that's the main thing that people
remember from this movie is that the
killer like talks like a duck and quacks
and stuff like that but you know we'll
get into that a little bit so the movie
opens up with a pretty good scene a man
is playing fetch with his dog like out
on this kind of like lake you know
riverside park or whatever but it
doesn't take too long before this game
of fetch goes hideously awry when the
little doggy comes back with
not a stick but with a decomposing human
hand
and turns out this hand
belongs to a model named ann lin
who has been brutally butchered and kind
of like left in these in this shrubbery
here by the side of the river her
landlady uh tells police that she had
actually been eavesdropping
on the young woman's phone calls as she
did uh and noted she's like oh she had
set up a date with this guy who talked
like a duck so
that's kind of their main lead that they
have to go on several weeks go by they
don't actually like tell you this it's
sort of like implied like as you know as
the dialogue goes on
so several weeks or a month or something
like that go by another young woman is
murdered this one is actually she's on a
ferry like she rode the bike onto the
ferry and there's like a car that's
parked on there and i'm assuming that
the car belongs to an ex-boyfriend of
hers or somebody that [ __ ] her over
because she wants to get into this car
and like write i guess she's gonna write
[ __ ] or something like that like in
lipstick like on his windshield so she
gets in there to do that but she ends up
getting murdered like in broad daylight
so at this point the rather world weary
investigators and the pathologist are
starting to suspect that there might be
a serial killer on the loose because the
stab wounds on the woman on the ferry
are very similar to the stab wounds that
were found on the woman that was you
know that the dog brought the hand and
everything like that
but the police chief who's actually
played by lucio fulci himself who
usually like inserted himself in a small
role in his movies and he does in this
case as well it's usually just one scene
um he kind of like admonishes everyone
hey you know keep your lips zipped uh we
don't want to prov we don't want to like
provoke a big city-wide panic meanwhile
there's this woman this super freak
named jane i think his her name is jane
one of her main activities things she
does for fun
is she likes to go to one of the many
live sex shows which i'm assuming were
all up and down 42nd street back in the
old days she goes in there watches the
live sex shows and uh you know pretty
much massages them off there while she's
like watching it she doesn't care who
sees she's a freak like that like i said
uh she also another thing she does is
she has this little bitty like tape
recorder and she kind of records the
sort of like orgasmic moaning of the
performers which i'm guessing she's
gonna use for later enjoyment so she can
like prolong
you know the fun uh now while she's in
there doing this she's actually spotted
by this kind of sinister looking dude
who has two fingers missing on his right
hand i think so not long after this sex
show ends uh the female performer that
was up on stage
she goes into her intensely giallo lit
dressing room it's great it's like this
just beautiful like vibrant like green
and it's like really cool with like the
red i just love that lighting so she's
in there and she gets shanked in the veg
by a broken wine bottle repeatedly like
many many times it's it's pretty nasty
it's pretty brutal you know and then she
bleeds to death obviously
so you know i mean there are some who
say that lucio folgi had some problems
had some issues with women i'm just
going to put that out there you know
just getting stabbed in the badge with a
broken mind yeah it's a lot so after
this the next potential target is faye
and she actually gets approached uh on
the subway like she's kind of buyers
like everybody gets off and she's on the
subway like going home and she gets
approached by the eight-fingered wonder
the creepy dude from the sex show
but she manages to evade him at least
for a time like she kind of gets off the
train and runs away and he chases her um
now her leg does get sort of like
viciously slashed so she's kind of like
limping and bleeding and everything like
that you know after like the attacker
catches up to her
after that it kind of goes in a little
bit of a weird there
it appears to be a nightmare sequence in
which like she's chased by this guy
presumably the eight-fingered guy from
the subway who we see very clearly like
you see what his face looks like it's
not like he's wearing a mask or nothing
but she gets slashed in the leg and then
there's like this weird like kind of
nightmare sequence where it looks like
her
sort of dashing young boyfriend whose
name is peter bunch
uh slashes her to death with a straight
razor
now she wakes up in the hospital i mean
obviously alive and unslashed
and peter is there and he's very
supportive and loving and whatnot like
presumably he has been this entire time
so she tells him about this dream that
she had she's like hey i had this dream
that you know after this guy chased me
like that you came and you killed me
like i saw your face and she starts to
speculate about why
she might have dreamed that and it's
something about like you don't find out
what it is until later on but she says
oh something about i'm sorry i didn't
understand about susie they don't tell
you until later on who susie is and what
that's all about so she says that she's
like yeah that's probably why i dreamed
that it was kind of upsetting but
whatever i know you'd never do anything
like that while peter sits there looking
very very obviously shifty so you know
what i mean so then we check back in
with jane the super freak who this time
around is getting her jollies by
going into this really sketchy dive
restaurant or bar or something like that
and sitting at a table by herself and
there's like all of these
this coterie of scumbags that are in
there and he she like allows one of them
to essentially like toe [ __ ] her after
the table it's pretty gross because i'm
like who knows where those feet have
been ew uh so after that like she runs
out of there because like she seems to
like it but then it upsets her i don't
know maybe that's how she gets her
jollies like i said i'm not judging uh
so she runs away and then makes an
appointment to
engage in some light bondage
with uh good old fingers missing man uh
you know the guy that's been chasing
everybody around
but like after they do the thing and
she's still tied to the bed and he's
fallen asleep then she finds out it's
like on the radio or some [ __ ] like that
that the guy that they're now calling
the new york ripper is also you know
short a couple digits so that might be
like a red flag something you want to
look at this guy that's sleeping right
here next to me and has me tied to the
bed also only has eight fingers so [ __ ]
now she is actually able to free herself
from her bonds
without waking the guy up but then she
like starts running out the hall there's
like all these doors locked and she
can't get out and she ends up getting uh
hacked to death in the hallway of this
fleabag hotel where they had been having
their rendezvous i also neglected to
mention that this pretty much this
entire time duckman the duck dude the
duxter duck dynasty whatever
has been phoning the police and sort of
like taunting them in his ridiculous ass
voice about them not being able to catch
him like basically i'm not gonna do it
but because i can't do it but basically
he's like calling them up and being like
quack quack quack
like he has this like ridiculous
doubting voice in a horrifying turn of
events the killer actually like as a
trick he sort of like has this elaborate
scheme where he ends up
making the cops go to like a different
place because he knows that they're
tracing the phone calls and [ __ ] like
that
while at the same time he's actually
savagely murdering the lead cop's
favorite prostitute whose name is kitty
who he goes to all the time and in again
a very horrifying scene that shows that
fulton maybe had some issues with women
basically kills her by slicing through
her nipple
and then like her eyeball with a like a
straight razor and so he he chops her up
like other places too but like using
like this little razor like she's tied
to the bed or whatever you know it
wouldn't be a full chew film uh unless
we had some squirm inducing eye trauma
so you get it here in loving close-up
just like you do like getting her
nipples laced in half so you know
there's that too another thing i forgot
to acknowledge in this whole stew
is the character of dr paul davis who's
actually played by uh paolo malco
who has also been housed by the cemetery
among other things
which is also a folger film case you
don't know
and he's kind of this smug chess playing
psychologist a psychologist psychiatrist
not entirely sure and he gets brought on
to the case as a profiler and he ends up
sort of like butting heads with the head
investigator lieutenant fred williams
over the characteristics of the
potential ripper whereas he thinks oh
this is a really intelligent guy like
somebody that comes from money somebody
that had some childhood trauma yada yada
and he's kind of arguing that the
eight-fingered guy
you know he probably is not the killer
because he seems too dumb to have like
pulled all this stuff off and it's kind
of this whole thing and then like the
cop is just kind of like well i know
what my gut blah blah blah so it's just
kind of like intelligence versus street
smarts kind of thing going on too which
is actually kind of interesting so the
cops are as i mentioned uh pretty
convinced that this menacing greek man
with the missing fingers is the killer
which
you know you could argue because you do
see him like do some [ __ ] so you know
it's not crazy that they think that but
there is a plot development later in the
film which i won't really spoil uh which
actually casts doubt on that assumption
though i'm gonna be honest uh if you're
watching the film with even half of your
attention it'll be pretty evident who
the ripper actually is you know what i'm
saying it's not like
it's not like one where they're making
it like a big huge secret they're a
little bit obvious with it but i will
say to you that that doesn't really
tarnish the kind of seedy allure fun or
whatever you want to call it that of
this movie but yeah don't go into this
expecting it to be some big mystery
whose reveal you won't see coming i mean
if you're watching it you'll pretty much
figure out what's going on
um you might not figure out like the
motive behind it but you'll probably
figure out what's going on having said
that uh i will you know kind of jumping
off from what i just said i will point
out this movie does have a pretty
bizarre motivation for the killer's
crimes uh that does matter of fact
involve a duck after a fashion it is
very much in the traditional uh sense of
the giallo where it's just kind of like
some kind of thing that either happened
in childhood or had to do with something
that happened in the past or something
to do with childhood that is causing a
person to
kill people and it's very much like that
but a little bit different now if you're
a luchio fulshi fan i can't imagine that
you haven't seen this as it's regularly
touted as one of his most controversial
which is saying a lot
uh shortly after its release it was
naturally relegated to the uk's video
nasties list
and the film as far as i'm aware was
banned out right there until as recently
as 2002
and i think it's still only available in
a censored version i mean at least as
far as i know if any of you guys are in
the uk and can uh tell me but i think
you can still only get it i don't think
it's like a huge amount is cut out but
some is cut out
you can get it uncut here as far as i'm
aware so yeah i mean i can kind of see
what like i said i don't really i'm i
don't agree with like cutting movies up
or like censoring them or anything like
that but
you can see that maybe
in comparison to some of his other like
films that are a lot gorier than this
because this is gory but it's not like
zombie or you know house by the cemetery
it's not gory like that but like i said
because those are more fantastical
because they're supernatural creatures
you can get away with a lot more when
you're doing something that's realistic
that's just about a ripper style killer
and it doesn't have any supernatural
elements then people are going to come
down harder on the violence i think and
i think especially this one i think a
lot of people thought it was kind of
like misogynist i mean a lot of the
murders are very very sexual in nature
um you know people getting like i said
you know that the woman getting like
[ __ ] stabbed in the vagina with a
broken bottle like just over and over
again so you know getting nipples sliced
in half and stuff like that so i can see
why people might have had a problem with
it it is kind of like a mean-spirited
movie it's kind of scuzzy it's kind of
borderline pornographic there's a lot of
like nudity there's a lot of simulated
sex in this like i said it kind of takes
place in this whole sleazy era of new
york city there's live sex shows there's
just you know there's masturbation
there's all kind of crazy [ __ ] going on
so it is kind of like riding that edge
and as i said it does kind of slaughter
women in very appallingly gruesome and
very very sexual ways which like i said
maybe
some people might have a problem with uh
and it does make kind of the streets of
new york city look like this neon lit
hellscape where
everyone you see is kind of like out to
exploit you or physically harm you or do
something in some way not gonna lie
though i've always kind of dug it it's
just kind of like especially since i've
seen like the restoration of it which
really shows
fulchi's kind of like artistic eye in a
way that you didn't really get to see
when it was just like the cheaper vhs
type style prints he really does know
how to like artfully frame this
grotesque vulgarity like for maximum
effect some of the shots in this are
legit like quite beautiful i will say
it's probably not
among my favorite folcie films
but if you're really into
ultra violent giallo movies uh that have
a massive side helping of smut i mean
you could certainly do a lot worse than
this one and if you like that kind of
thing then i would absolutely recommend
it although like i said it's not for
everybody so go into it with that like
go into it if you liked maniac you'll
probably like this one as well because
it's along similar lines although this
one i would argue is nastier than maniac
which like i i realize that that's also
saying a lot so that'll do it for this
flickers of fear uh continuing on with
giallo july and i will see you guys on
the next one bye